okay please don't get in death damn it
Marga block can you and dodge his attack
then you kill him don't quit you can do
it hold good oh hey it's Slendy man
why is Slender Man so big what am I
supposed to do oh come on he punches me
punches me whoa
got you Oh what oh hey hey whoa whoa
okay i well alright then land here then
press Z Z whoa Oh
Wilford war fast punch awesome creative
think cast me god damn you are good at
making your like the best happy wheels
level maker ever markiplier impossible
I'm going for a ride apparently and then
I'm gonna go into the winner's circle
right now
Marga Blair obstacle course easy I've
been told things are easy before they
never end up and they get that way okay
I'm alive no oh oh no oh come on what am
i doing what have a goddamn this kid see
my kids don't even hear it he's causing
me problems
oh come on we're all alive it was only
the one thing Oh No fans gonna get out
of this alive Tanith work
Santa thinks Santa might not make it but
Santa's gonna God
our two-in-one I hope you enjoy and mark
if you're playing this thank you for all
the laughter Thank You Jacob for making
this I'm sure that I'm not gonna get it
in the death and I'm gonna win yeah I'm
one per a Oh also jacksepticeye I
thought this was my game Jack you get
out of here hang on wait no god damn it
damn it damn it damn it I wanted to win
burglar ball run supposedly possible if
you could have lined up the bottles in
some even order god that was so close
incredible just the sheer speed at which
I die oh that was like the closest I've
been doing there's like 10,000 times
dammit it's really impossible
markiplier bread kill this is a Caspi
level I knew I was gonna expect
something amazing and oh my goodness
gracious
we're all bread I have two little
swinging tiny box breads tiny tiny bread
Jim tiny bread Tim I have no idea
kind of the same thing but again whoa
hello hi again goodbye forever oh hi hey
big bucks Barry
how are you doing there's van is it's
it's a bunch of assets from previous
games that Caspi is made it's like a
conglomeration I win I've got a leg
sticking out of my head but I win Marga
blyer hard 100% I don't know if that's a
commentary on me or the game okay it's
game
what hell you only got my side hi ow ow
ow
free sure that was straight up my balls
help just go come on
I've won just give me over the goddamn
ramp Hey
thank you well then I wasn't Margaret
I'm not impossible just in damn its
markiplier shorty how dare you sir short
and sweet and to the point very
challenging but not impossible talking
about Oh
markiplier spin bridge holy crap well
that's weird
out of the blue and now I got arrows up
my crotch know anything I don't think
it's supposed to explode quite so
readily right off the bat oh crap ow ow
ow ow
oh you're done okay I'll move on then
okay well then it was markiplier dance
but I'm not entirely sure what's going
on markiplier ball fun I was hoping by
the name of this that it was gonna be a
ball fight he just have a little bit of
fun you know flail out of it but it
stopped [ __ ] ball bed yay oh my god
I'm so ready the silliest thing but it's
awesome I can't get very far down into
it too like real ball pitch you can't
wiggle your way down to the bottom but
go my god hey oh wow going back hurts
Anna they're still rolling Oh God
don't read this Oh goddamn it shouldn't
hurt smuggler kills oh no no what are
you making wine markiplier double this
is supposed to be hard why am i sward
throwing into him this is a ball throw
what died I didn't mean to do that okay
oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] oh I blocked it okay
good Oh huh
god dammit last try glorious when I did
it I did it what do I win what do I win
oh it's a ball ow my legs God mark oh
it's tiny bites Tim and you know tiny
Boxey me loves to kill everyone he ever
owned oh he's being very gentle to them
see tiny box tim is a lover not a
fighter but where's he going now oh I
think I died in there well that's the
end of tiny box Tim's journey he's gonna
sit there and stare at you forever
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
you